Silicon Valley Bank was the home of tech
startups the 16th largest lender in
America and held around 200 billion
dollars in assets it collapsed on March
10th the biggest lender to do so since
the global financial crisis many of its
deposits were larger than the two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars that
is covered by federal Insurance
Regulators stepped in to mitigate the
damage every American should feel
confident that their deposits will be
there if and when they need them but it
has exposed some serious flaws in
America's banking architecture our Wall
Street correspondent explains what
happened and what might happen next
Silicon Valley Bank mostly caters to the
tech industry and over the past three
years the tech industry has been booming
they've raised a lot of money for
venture capital and they were all
banking with Silicon Valley bank now all
of these customers are commercial
customers and because they Place large
deposits with Silicon Valley Bank that
means that they all covered by Deposit
Insurance a program that protects
depositors from losses in the event that
their Bank fails so that was one problem
the other problem for Silicon Valley is
that it is immersed a huge pot of
deposits from these tech companies over
the past three years but it was
struggling to make loans to those same
companies so instead it used those
deposits and it bought a lot of Treasury
Securities which is debt issued by the
American government and mortgage-backed
securities as well and those assets were
very very sensitive to Rising interest
rates so Earth's interest rates went up
the value of all the assets that Silicon
Valley Bank had bought board fell
sharply so when people realized the
value of its assets had fallen and that
it might be insolvent all of its
customers had a real incentive to run to
pull their assets from the bank as
quickly as they can and that is exactly
what happened
the treasury announced that all
depositors in Silicon Valley Bank and
another bank called Signature which also
failed were going to be made whole so
even the uninsured deposits that
companies are placed with Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank were going to be
redeemable in full that is a new
intervention that the treasury has not
made before in one of these bank
failures and at the same time the
Federal Reserve launched a new lending
facility which would allow Banks to post
good high quality assets like treasuries
like I'm always about Securities in a
new facility to borrow against them at
quite generous rates and the combination
of those two things was supposed to try
and stop contagion from spreading across
the banking system
this episode raises two big questions
about the financial system the first is
whether the regulatory apparatus that
Banks currently exist under is
appropriate Silicon Valley Bank and
other Banks of its size were Exempted on
a lot of the regulations put in place
post-crisis in part because it was
thought that their failure wouldn't pose
a systemic risk to the financial system
but as we've seen
when there was a run on a bank as big a
Silicon Valley Bank that quickly led to
fears of runs at other institutions that
suggests that there were systemic risks
associated with the bank of that side is
failing and maybe those thresholds need
to be rethought the second big question
is about whether we'll see problems
elsewhere in the financial system you've
seen financial institutions in the
hottest parts of the economy so crypto
with the failure of FTX and now Tech
with the failure of Silicon Valley Bank
you've seen those institutions come
unstuck first as interest rates have
climbed it's not yet clear whether the
full impact of interest rates has
rippled through the entire Financial
system and revealed all the institutions
that might be struggling with the
consequences
thank you so much for watching to read
more of our coverage of the Silicon
Valley Bank collapse click the link and
don't forget to subscribe